combien vous rapporter la facebook et 83
cents c'est ce que gagne facebook en
vous montrant de la publicité chaque
jour vous vous dites peut-être juste 83
cents et oui mais attendez 83 cents par
jour et les jours du iona 365 dans une
année et ça c'est juste vous multipliez
sa part environ 25 millions d'abonnés au
pays ça donne sept milliards cinq cent
soixante treize millions sept cent
cinquante mille dollars
comprenez vous maintenant pourquoi
facebook veut tout savoir sur vous
exemple vous aimez les films d'époque
être fan de marilyn avait un chien et un
budget alloué pour le chien vous
pourriez trouver ce produit tant
irrésistible facebook s'est tiré profit
de plomb de sensible alors faites
attention aux achats impulsifs ou passés
le mot
[Musique]